[Music]
in today's eight on your side getting a
sleep coach
it is the latest wellness trend so how
does it work and do you need one
well according to the cdc a third of us
adults battle poor sleep
they get less than six hours of sleep a
night and this has only gotten worse
during the pandemic
so if you're saying that's me well the
company proper offers a personalized and
holistic approach with board certified
health and wellness sleep coaches like
kelly o'brien
the first thing we do when we're
coaching is we really try to find out
for each individual client what
their ideal night of sleep could look
like for them
and it really varies and it helps
clients understand
that their own sleep needs something
they should be familiar with or
get familiar with not everybody needs
the perfect eight hours and of course
some of us are night owls and others are
morning folks and we've got everybody in
between
she adds there is a lot of science
behind sleep and sleep needs
proper pairs the sleep coaching with
formulations designed to maximize the
different stages of sleep that clients
go through
offering a combo of natural sleep
supplements to get that better sleep we
all crave